one day I just saw fake news article
about Justin Trudeau especially at a
time where you have like Donald Trump we
will make our country great again Justin
Trudeau seems like the polar opposite of
that nasty polluted vote thank you very
very much
I can't remember the last time we saw
interest internationally in one of our
prime ministers like Justin Trudeau the
thirst is strong is all I can really say
that's interesting so it first came up
for you because it's just like you shot
on Facebook or it's trending but you
were like just ha momentum at and this
is this article popped up or someone
sent it to you yeah that's it
there's a site called hot global news
which I'd never heard of take a quick
look at it it kind of looks like a real
news site almost all of their stories
were about Justin Trudeau they were all
totally faked so you know Justin Trudeau
is going to open up marijuana stores
across the country Justin Trudeau has
banned Donald Trump from coming into
Canada I mean they just had all these
crazy stories there the first thing that
that I always do is I do what's called a
who is search so I wanted to see who
owned Hawk global news.com actually let
me just put to see I can remember if
they had hidden it or not there is
actually a name attached to it
it's llaman a boy bad so Hawk Global
News is their biggest page and has a
little over ninety thousand likes on it
which is actually pretty impressive like
pretty good work on their part if you
want to put it that way maybe they're
proud of what they do or they're
unconcerned about consequences for it or
perhaps they're naive and they don't
kind of realize that you know they're
making money fooling people and that
that may not be perceived as a good
thing and at one point I find a listing
of somebody with this name winning an
award for web programming a picture is
starting to form in my mind without
having you know
this person that you know is building
websites who is you know playing around
online who's also I guess got a bit of
an entrepreneurial spirit and it's
trying to figure out how they can make
some money from their their web skills
and I realized that you know holy [ __ ]
this is actually a teenager who's doing
this um I'm going grade 11 AB 16 years
old I own ha global news the National
Sun and the global Sun and you know and
and you know the question is like is
this is this kid aware that what they're
doing would be C has you know very
unethical but they like especially like
when I watch the interview footage II
definitely a sweet kid and maybe no
moral center we get along comments and
base Kahler posting fake satire BS um
I'd say a lot of them know it's fake
what percentage of people are in on the
joke do you have any sense of that I
didn't know its satire yeah see now that
I think about it um you know don't think
if they think it's real and that's the
idea right is to come up with a name and
a website that looks real No
frankly some of the articles that are on
that site the really you know negative
ones about Trudeau are you know are
potentially really damaging like I one
point they published an article saying
that Justin Trudeau had been arrested
for for domestic assault and they had
other articles of him being arrested for
like being high while driving I do do
you worry that some people might
actually believe those and and you know
think something of Trudeau or of that
person whose photo was in it yeah
actually a lot of us think that were a
mom we hate liberals and the word
conservative fans the truth is we just
we're not anything like a lot people
think that um I'm not be honest word but
santa phobia did I'm against Muslims and
thing is I am Muslim so I wouldn't be
against Muslims we it just because it's
not biased or anything do you do you
think that people who are anti Muslim
might read the one about the Isis member
disguised as a refugee and and and
spread that around and that might look
course most definitely is do you I mean
do you think about that ethical side of
it at all like oh are you guys you know
scaring people or frightening people or
anything like that um yeah I think we
are is that is that the appeal for you
because you know I like I think a lot of
people assume that folks who make these
kinds of sites one maybe they get off on
fooling people or two they're just in it
for the money so like what is it for you
that you like about this I don't like
the fooling people we get a lot of hate
galon lot of hate but it's just really
just the money